welcome to the second annual st. Louis
norm event the st. Louis classic this
tournament is split into two fields one
for the grandmasters and the GM norm
hunters and the other is for the
International masters and the IM norm
hunters in the grand master section John
Bartholomew was the only norm seeker to
win this round he defeated Darwin yang
with white I played several norm
tournaments before not a ton of like
clothes norm tournaments round-robin
format so it's nice to play in this one
feel like your chances are always better
to make a GM norm in a closed tournament
nowadays I do a lot of tests coaching so
I don't get a chance to play as much but
I'm very happy to be here and playing in
a norm tournament because i usually
don't get these opportunities so I
played this move Queen to b4 in this
position here and I thought the position
was already a little difficult for him
because his b7 and d6 ponds are under
attack he played pretty natural looking
move Queen c7 defending both ponds and
here i thought i could play c5 and just
open up the position and it seemed
pretty thematic he doesn't have a dark
square Bishop so his dark squares are
going to be kind of weak and after I
place c5 there's a threat on d6 he's
pretty much obligated to take it and I
took back with the Queen which threatens
the 97 here I was really expecting night
to g6 but he really surprised me he took
on d5 instead just sacrificing the night
which may be under the circumstances was
a pretty good practical decision because
after i take the night he takes on e4
and due to a couple tricks like I can't
play night before here because he plays
either up to e8 my queen is trapped so
the principal thing to do is just to
retreat the night that you one try to
hold on to the piece so I did that he
played rook fe8 with my queen back and
then his idea is Bishop b5 to threaten
my rock on f1 and he's going to win the
material back
but in the resulting position I have two
minor pieces and feel it's really tough
for him and Darwin was also getting into
pretty bad time pressure around about
here so that definitely works in my
favor I played Bishop b5 he took on f1 I
took back give a check and when King g1
and if we go forward a little bit h3
Darwin said this was strong after the
game he felt that this was maybe a
turning point kind of inclined to agree
h6 so responding to an attack with an
attack shop those minor pieces and now I
want to win the e4 pawn if I can win the
e4 pawn cleanly this should be really
good for white if not winning the two
minor pieces so I went here and here he
hits the pawn on b2 with this move so
especially under time pressure i didn't
want trade queens or anything so Queenie
to holding on to the pond and still
threatening efore and he pushed messing
up my pawn structure and this moment
right here he was very low on time and
we sought to make the time control of 40
I had a little think because I felt like
there was something strong for white in
this position and I think I found the
right solution I mean haven't had a
chance to check it yet but I traded
Queens and then played Bishop b5 just
giving my Jeep on but the double
isolated g pawns are not that important
to white it's more important to get
activity for my pieces so I felt like
this is really key because if I play
some move like you know defending the
Jeep on or something else maybe Pawnee
for then my minor pieces are really
restricted so Bishop d5 was key because
I give up the pond but after this his
rooks are really uncoordinated and my
position just got better and better than
here as we see the standings for the
first time it's important to note that
Irina Krush has earned herself the GM
title already it just has yet to be made
official in the international master
section costilla kavinsky was the only
norm seeker to grab a point this round
he defeated Jeffrey Zhang with black so
you kind of have to forget about the age
and try to respect each of
it because kids are especially really
strong in tactical situations where
there's a lot of complications and
that's that's where you lose but we got
this end game you just play the movie 5
and I think that why it's definitely
playing to win here just because his d6
bond is so strong as Rick and Bishop are
so active well here I played rook e8 I
don't think I have any other moves
otherwise his pieces are too active and
you might promote his deep on and now he
actually played rook takes a 6 which I
thought was maybe even a serious mistake
i thought d7 was the best move and then
i have to play Rick d 8 and then e6 I
have to take Bishop takes and now he's
threatening Rick c8 which would promote
the pond so I have no choice but to play
King f8 so i can play king g7 and defend
the rook and here i figured that you
know he can play some over this Bishop
like Bishop f5 and I'm basically stuck
my ruck and King are extremely passive
because of this pawn and next he can
either take the h6 pawn or the a6 pawn
rook is super active I don't know if
whites winning by force here but it's
really really unpleasant for black
because I just have no no active moves
but instead he took this pawn in a 6
which gave me a lot of chances not to
draw but even to win the game so I took
on e5 he play Bishop c6 and then I put
Ricky to check King f1 Rick d2 and you
took this pawn on d5 so now we both have
three pawns but the difference here is
that my Rick and Bishop are perfectly
placed and I have my Rick behind his
deep on it can't really promote itself
so easily and his work and Bishop are in
the really awkward position so I play
Bishop g4 to prevent d 7 and now I think
black is actually better here I think
whites in any pretty huge trouble
because is deep on a stock and
my age pawn is getting ready to just run
down the board and it seems pretty fast
so he played king he won ruke d1 looking
f2 and here i just played h5 and i'm not
sure if you are still trying to win at
this moment i think he realized that he
might be in trouble so he tried to bail
out with Rick c6 which is a clever move
because if I play Bishop d7 he has Rick
c5 and the g5 ponens up hanging with
check but instead I just played h4 and
now I just want to pull my bishop back
and then play g4 and g3 and because this
King is so badly placed I think my pawns
are are a lot stronger just cuz ii i can
create some kind of mating threats as
well as you try and promote the ponds so
he played a 4 i'm not sure if actually
why can defend or fried away find a way
to equalize a position so he just kind
of went forward here to push his a pond
and we were both down to like two or
three minutes so there wasn't a whole
lot of lines we could calculate here we
sort of just had to to play an instinct
so I played the show e 6 to get my Jeep
on rolling Bishop e2 and Rick d for now
I want to take his beef or pawn if he
lets me you played a five and here I
figured I don't don't really need to
take this be four point I don't see how
it helps me so I just played g4 and I
was able to calculate something here and
I felt like I was definitely promoting
first if it was just a clear race like
it happened in the game and so this was
a pretty good evaluation so he played a
six he's really got nothing else at this
point g3 check and now if king g 1 i'm
just going to play Rick takes before and
I think black is winning by force the
point is that a seven
I play rugby one check and if King g2i
Bishop d5 check and I win the rook and
looks like oh it looks like I might even
just be why stop as pawns and I can
promote my own and then the bishop f1
then Bishop h3 and you can queen but I
just take on f1 and its mate so I think
you saw this line and he played King III
to try and complicate things so I played
g2 and it's basically forced this is
king to go back and here i played rukka
for checked I really don't know if this
is the best move I mean the evaluation
might swing from black is winning two
white is winning two equal but this
seemed like the right idea you can't
take the pawn again because of a bishop
d5 check so we had to play king g 1 and
here i found this move h3 which i think
is pretty strong and the point is that
if he plays a 7 i'm going to play rick h
4 and if he queens and I'll pull h2 with
track queen with check and then probably
have a force mate there when you're
Queen with check you just assume that
you're going to make the open King and
if you play something like King h2
instead of cleaning then I think I just
queen he takes I give a check and I
bishop d5 check again or actually I just
queen the check
so he played rooks III and this is just
um just the losing move I mean he had
almost no time at this point so i took
this be four pawn now I've got ideas to
play rugby one and rick h one mate or
just bring the pawn so he played king h2
Rick be one now I just want a queen so
we have to play Richard III check King
gage six and here if he keeps his work
on g3 then I just play rock h1 mate so
the game is more or less over he
sacrificed his rep but of course in this
position black has a million ways to way
and I played row k 1 and you basically
resign for any player in either section
one needs six and a half points by the
end of the round robin to qualify for a
norm costilla has high hopes and he's on
his way watch the games live online at
us chess champs calm and watch for these
daily updates on our youtube channel stl
chess club don't forget to subscribe